"John Wick: Chapter 4" blasts its
way into theaters on March 24, 2023,
and the people who have seen it say it's, well,
a blast. Though they also have a few minor
quibbles about the assassin's latest outing.
The next "John Wick" movie looms ever closer,
and it looks like it's going to be another hit
for Keanu Reeves' titular assassin. Expectations
for the movie have been sky-high, bolstered by a
set of trailers and teases that suggest this
latest outing may be the most thrill-packed
entry in the series yet. Even Reeves himself has
gone on record to say that "John Wick: Chapter 4"
blows away everything that's come before in terms
of its action sequences. That's a very high bar.
"'John Wick: Chapter 4'! This movie is crazy!"
With such sky-high expectations, some
may find themselves worried that the
flick isn't going to live up to the hype.
After all, it's a lot of pressure to put on
the fourth entry in a blockbuster franchise.
All you have to do is look at 2022's "Thor:
Love and Thunder" to know that fourth entries
sometimes suffer from diminishing returns.
But despite these concerns,
it seems that nervous fans
have nothing to fear. Critics who attended
early pre-release screenings of "John Wick:
Chapter 4" have a lot of good things to say
about the upcoming flick. CinemaBlend's Eric
Eisenberg tweeted that he was pleased to
find that despite "John Wick: Chapter 4"
being the longest movie in the franchise
yet, its extended runtime feels warranted.
"It's an epic with smart pacing that
never lets the action feel exhausting,
and the set pieces are phenomenal."
Fandango's Erik Davis was similarly
impressed by the film's level of quality,
particularly in its action
sequences. Davis tweeted,
"This is definitely the biggest
& most badass 'JOHN WICK' movie
yet [with] a runtime near 3 hours & an
ending everyone will be talking about.
No one does action like this – it's on
another level. Part 4 simply rules."
Beyond the stellar action sequences, critics
have also heaped praise on the movie's cast,
which features a mix of series
veterans and newcomers to the
franchise. Critic Matt Neglia
of Next Best Picture wrote,
"Keanu Reeves continues to push his body
to the limit while Donnie Yen & Hiroyuki
Sanada add real gravitas to the most
epic film of the franchise yet."
But even with all those positive reactions,
there are also a fair few critics out there
that feel the movie falls short in some minor
regards. Total Film's Jordan Farley found the
film's action to be a little excessive
and a touch too over the top, writing,
"Moment to moment fight choreography is as
thrilling as ever but the set-pieces don't
have enough variety to sustain
their jumbo size. Wick's 'Looney
Tunes' pratfalls stretch credulity,
even in a world this heightened."
"Well, it looks like we have ourselves a…a
genuine conundrum. A quandary, if you will."
Others have griped a bit about the film's
length. Critic Sean Mulvihill mostly said
good things, but noted it went on too long.
Variety's Simon Thompson called "John Wick:
Chapter 4" "exhilarating as it is
exhausting." It seems those hoping
for a breezy action flick may find the
scope and scale of the film overwhelming.
Perhaps the most intriguing critique
of "John Wick: Chapter 4," however,
has to do with the ending. Based on
early reactions, it seems the film goes
in an unexpected direction as it reaches its
conclusion. Insider's Kirsten Acuna predicted:
"Lots of surprises in this one that's
going to deliver a divisive ending."
Nonetheless, a fifth "John Wick"
installment is confirmed to be
on the way, so make of that warning what you will.